-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy Award-winning acto
you know from his work
in "The Birdcage,"
"Ray Donovan,"
and "The Simpsons."
All four seasons
of his show "Brockmire"
are streaming on Hulu now.
Here's my conversation
with Hank Azaria.
Welcome back, Hank.
How are ya?
-I'm hangin' in there, Seth.
How you doin'?
-I'm doin' alright.
I wanna start by talking
about the Mets.
Usually, we would be
in a completely different
part of the season.
You're both a Mets fan
and a Knicks fan
and, with those teams,
has the pause on live sports
been good
for your mental health,
or do you still
desperately miss it?
-Both.
I mean --
I saw somebody posted
online yesterday like,
"Wow! I watched a movie
tonight that I enjoyed,
where, normally,
I would just have freaked ou
and got wildly frustrated
with the Mets.
I mean, what have I been
thinking all these years?
[ Laughter ]
Peace in my life."
Yeah, but, you know,
on the one hand, it's fun --
it's a relief not to watch the
Knicks and Mets fail miserably
On the other hand,
I'd sort of give anything
to watch them fail miserably
[ Laughing ] right now.
-Yeah.
My father-in-law loves music
the way I love sports
and I realized that,
when he goes to a concert,
there's never a chance
that he's gonna leave upset.
Like the band is gonna
play the hits,
whereas, just you're
flippin' a coin
[ Laughing ] when you go
see a sports game.
I wanna talk about "Brockmire"
and I wanna get to like
how the character has evolved,
but this started as sort o
a classic sketch character
that has now --
which is incredible --
endured four seasons
on television.
But how did you first come u
with the character?
-[ As Brockmire ]
This is the voice
of Jim Brockmire.
I call it the generic '70s
baseball announcer voice.
And, you know, I was,
you know, 15 years old.
I'm gonna tell you the story
as Jim Brockmire, Seth.
I was 15 years old
and the year was 1979.
And, right about then,
it started occurring to me that,
"Why do all these guys
talk this way?"
Do they always sound --
Do they sound like this
in their personal lives?
Like when they're dirty-talkin
their good lady wives
during sex, does it still
come out this way?
Do they sound this way
when they're wasted?
Also, Harry Shearer and I
at "The Simpsons" noticed --
We talk a lot.
He does an amazing Vin Scully,
Harry Shearer.
It's one of those impression
that like you can't tell
the difference
between actual Vin Scully
and Harry Shearer.
-[ Laughing ] Sure.
-And we noted
that baseball announcers
can say pretty much
whatever they like,
as long as they give the count
afterwards, you know, so.
[ As Brockmire ]
Hey, I spent most
of last evening
with an 8 ball of cocaine
and a prostitute.
As Johnson swings and misses
at the breaking ball, 0-1.
-[ Laughing ]
-And --
So, that became like
the comic premise,
is just, "What weird stuff
can you say and give the count
and then, do these guys
always talk like this?"
And you know what's funny?
You know,
given your "SNL" roots,
by the time I was about --
about 15 years ago maybe, like
so I must've been about 40
in my early 40s
and like I always wanted
to be on "SNL."
I always felt like my skill se
would've been good over there.
-Very much so. It would've
been a very good fit.
-Never did I have
the opportunity.
And I don't write
for myself very well,
so, it just wasn't
a natural for me.
And so, I walked
into my agent's office.
I'm like, "You know,
I'm not on 'SNL.'
Where can I have
these bunch of characters?
Where can I do 'em?"
They were, like, "Well,
you know, will Ferrell created
'Funny or Die' for almost
exactly this purpose."
-And it really does speak
to how funny the sketch
was in the beginning
and I think, you know,
if you watch the pilot episode
it feels like sort of a sex romp
and this funny idea
of a guy coming undone.
And, yet, it's -- you know, yo
guys have attacked addiction
You've attacked relationships.
And, I mean,
it's mind-blowing to me
that you did this
fourth season --
obviously, you filmed it
before any
of 2020 started getting crazy.
But you jumped basically 10,
15 years into the future.
Baseball is hanging on
for dear life.
The world is coming undone
I mean, do you guys talk
about how far ahead
of the curve you were
and how unfortunate, that yo
[ Laughing ] were so right
-I think it was wildly
precognitive, Season 4.
Yeah, I mean, the first
five minutes of Season 4,
you get this like
faux "Today" show opening
where there's a pandemic.
There's rioting in the streets
What wasn't so hard to predict
ten years from now
is that the average
temperature might be 170°°
but the fact that baseball's
very near death.
Who would've thought that
there'd be more baseball
in a fictitious
ten years from now
than there is
in the reality of 2020?
That's Joel Church-Cooper.
You know, my take on the
character was that romp,
that raunchy romp,
that the short was --
It was pretty sophomoric,
you know.
I made the character
an alcoholic just
to justify saying outlandish
[bleep]. Pardon me.
-[ Laughing ]
-Outlandish crap on the air.
But he saw the depth of a ma
struggling with his alcoholism
and all that that implies
and trying to find --
Like baseball, trying to fin
relevance in modern times.
I'm, like, "What did you
write here, man?
It's brilliant."
Yeah, I got lucky.
-Well, I wonder like
what has it been like for you,
as an actor, that you create
a character that,
you know, not to, you know
devalue it at all,
seems like a sketch character,
and then, you find this writer
that's given him
all this depth
and you're into it
as this really fun,
like vocal impression.
Has that made it easier
for you to --
Because you're so great
at playing the reality
of this person.
Starting with the silly voice,
has it made playing
the dark parts easier,
or has it been harder?
-Kind of both.
I mean, a lot of my gig
or my niche or my schtick,
if you will,
is creating a silly voice
and then seeing
if I can fill it in
as much as possible.
It's almost like a game.
Like can I make this
a real human being?
And it became a fun challenge.
Like Amanda Peet,
who plays Brockmire's love
she's great, and she's ver
real and raw, you know,
and it's a great character
she's playing.
So we'll have these intens
conversations in the show,
where she's crying
and screaming and upset
and I've gotta
answer her in kind,
[ As Brockmire ]
but I've gotta say it like this.
-[ Laughing ]
-I've gotta talk to her
as from baseball.
And I know, in my mind,
I'm like,
"Oh, Amanda's really upset
I gotta take care of her,
[ As Brockmire ]
but it's gonna come
out of this filter.
And can I make
that sound sincere?
And, you know, that's been
the fun of the character.
-Well, you know what I do?
I wanna tip my cap
to both of you
because you stay
in the character
and she has done
such a fantastic job of --
she now accepts --
you know, her character
accepts your character as real
and that's what makes it
such a fun show to watch,
as opposed to something
that I think could've been
so much broader
and less effective.
We'll be right back with mor
Hank, right after this.